[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist kein großes geheimnis dass die
sogenannte volksrepublik china ein
letzter zeit nicht gerade das
beliebteste land der welt ist mit
vorfällen mit dem ausdruck des corona
werde es höchstwahrscheinlich aus einem
chinesischen labor dem angriff auf die
freiheit hongkongs den ständigen drogen
im gegenteil bahn und den problemen mit
krediten an arme länder hat die china
eine ganz bestimmte spitzenposition
gesichert ganz weit oben auf der liste
der beliebtesten länder der welt und das
ist noch nicht alles als ob das alles
nicht genug wäre trägt eine neue direkt
von der spitze der pseudo
kommunistischen partei chinas
vorgegebene politische linie langsam
aber sicher dazu bei die popularität des
reister mit dem ausland vollends zu
zerstören ich spreche von der neuen
diplomatie shipping etabliert hat
es handelt sich nämlich um eine viel
härtere und aggressivere art der
diplomatie die inoffiziell wurde floh
matti getauft wurde der titel einer
erfolgreichen excel serie schien
astronom zu hollywood rambo reihe eine
politik die von vielen analysten im
wesentlichen als strategie der
erpressung und des zwangs bezeichnet
wird wobei diese strategie angesichts
der vorliegenden daten ehrlich gesagt
nicht besonders effektiv zu sein scheint
zumindest nicht was die beliebtheit des
landes im rest der welt angeht
hört mal einen blick auf diese grafik in
nur fünf jahren zwischen den frühling
2015 und dem sommer 2020 ist die meinung
so china in vielen der führenden
volkswirtschaften der welt komplett
abgestürzt china hat sich von einem land
mit einigen dem prestige zum feindbild
der internationalen gemeinschaft
entwickelt und das hat natürlich auch
damit zu tun wie china mit dem rest der
welt umspringt
die preisfrage in diesem spiel lautet
jedoch nimmt ist peking eventuell
billigend in kauf sich in der ganzen
welt unbeliebt zu machen weil es sich im
gegenzug etwas erhofft was den damit
einhergehenden machtverlust mehr als
ausgleichen kann eine ganz neue stellung
des reichs der mitte in der welt nun um
diese frage im rahmen einer ganzen serie
von videos zu beantworten werden wenn in
diesem video einen genauen blick auf die
sogenannte waiver diplomatie werfen wir
werden die neue methode untersuchen wir
das reich der mitte sich dafür
entschieden hat jeden widersacher der
chinas wege kreuzt einen ordentlichen
denkzettel zu verpassen also aufgepasst
[Musik]
der drache weste seine krallen
liebe visual politik zuschauer es
scheint als ob das bescheinigt china
dass china der besonnenen worte und
bedachten taten völlig verschwunden ist
das wohl die china das denkt shopping so
sehr wollte gibt es nicht mehr natürlich
bleibt die frage bestehen ob denn in
seiner unendlichen weisheit nicht
einfach nur zeit schinden wollte bis
china wieder aufgestiegen ist wie dem
auch sei cheap and hat den ganzen ein
ende gesetzt jetzt ist die ära der wolfs
krieger angebrochen
[Musik]
diese sogenannte victoria diplomatie ist
nicht nur eine änderung der
außenpolitischen linie sondern ein
kompletter paradigmenwechsel eine 180
grad wende sowohl in china sicht aus dem
glas in der weltordnung als auch darin
auf welche weise peking seine
erstattende wirtschaftliche und
militärische präsenz zur geltung bringen
will
tja so einfach und doch so komplex aber
ohren genau besteht diese art der
diplomatie die würze in der praxis
durchgeführt und welche veränderungen
hat titel wirkt nun ja eine der
wichtigsten veränderungen ist der
militärische ansatz um einen wolf oder
zu werden muss man angst einflößen
können und genau das hat china mit
seinem verbesserten militärischen
fähigkeiten und seiner zunehmenden
aggressivität in der region getan wir
haben darüber schon in früheren videos
berichtet und ich werde die eines davon
in der beschreibung verlinken doch nicht
nur auf dem militärische schachbrett hat
sich einiges verändert chinas neuer stil
der diplomatie geht weit über bloße
militärische macht hinaus
die diplomatie der wulff arias beruht
auf einer holistischen einer
ganzheitlichen vision dabei muss man
sich vor augen führen dass die
diplomatie immer mehr an vorderster
front steht ein großer teil des
personals in chinesischen botschaften
und konsulaten hat inzwischen zb die
aufgabe des informationen zu verbreiten
steak news zu fabrizieren und
gleichgesinnte journalisten und
kommunikatoren versuchen und zu
unterstützen
die rote linie hat sich verschoben es
geht nicht mehr um feinabstimmung
sondern um die durchführung von klaren
aktivismus koste es was es wolle man
könnte sagen dass die chinesische
diplomatie eines der effektivsten mittel
der mord währenden konflikt führung
entdeckt hat die sozialen medien eine
armee von fake fans wusstet ihr dass
beiträge auf twitter das alles geschieht
natürlich sowohl in sozialen medien als
auch anderenorts aber das ist
selbstverständlich so die spitze des
eisbergs ein werkzeug und das dealen im
rahmen einer strategie deren
schlüsselelement politische und
wirtschaftliche konsequenzen sind ja
genau völlig richtig schießen hat
beschlossen dass china seinen
widersachern eine ordentliche lektion
erteilen muss passt jetzt also gut auf
denn mit dem was wir euch im folgenden
erzielen werden werdet ihr endlich den
grossen der aktuellen entwicklungen
verstehen können bevor wir doch zur tat
schreiten müssen sie uns alle bei
unserem sponsor bedanken der das heutige
web ermöglicht hat ibm wenn wir nämlich
schon ein sponsoring angebot annehmen
muss es um etwas gehen von dem wir
selbst denken das ist für unsere
zuschauer eine wirklich sinnvolle
dienstleistung darstellt und ein
sicheres vpn dass weder datenverkehr
noch meter oder verbindungsdaten mit
lockt ist für uns alle ganz bestimmt
etwas hochgradig sinnvoll ist denn
anonymität und sicherheit im netz sind
ein immer kostbares gut und alle sollten
so viel wie möglich dafür tun deswegen
müssen wir unbedingt den überaus
verlässlichen und werten vpn service von
sky ans herz legen swatch art bietet
unzählige sicherheitschef zum beispiel
clean bleibt dass alle cookies popups
und auch fortgeschrittene
identifizierung und nachverfolgung
mechanismen von dem man oft gar nichts
ahnt sicher bloggt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren seit ich natürlich
konnte er mit dessen hilfe auch auf
websites und internet dienste zugreifen
die in dem land in dem ihr alle seid
nicht verfügbar sind ohne zensur gut
geblockt ob daheim oder im urlaub
netflix und andere streaming dienste die
ihre inhalte nur in den usa anbieten von
europa aus nutzen mit surf start kein
problem aber nicht nur das mit nur einem
schlag konnte könnt ihr alle eure geräte
im vpn registrieren handys notebooks
oder sogar euren smart tvs denkt
wirklich alle arten von geräten ab er
bekommt damit einen lückenlosen schutz
suchen wenn ihr den rabattcode
politik.de angibt bekommt ihr von selbst
auch noch ein rabatt von 83% und
obendrein die ersten drei monate gratis
dazu den link zu diesem angebot findet
ihr in der beschreibung unter diesem
video also nichts wie los besorgt euch
surft und greift damit gleich die uns
finanziell unter die arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des
paypal spenden links den ich ebenfalls
in die beschreibung gepackt habe wir
sind euch für jede unterstützung dankbar
denn damit hält er uns euch in zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere videos zu
liefern so und nun das uns schnell
wieder zum thema dieses videos
zurückkehren zu schießen ping und seinen
puls kriegen also los geht's
[Musik]
pekings rote linien zu überschreiten hat
seinen preis
während russland die usa frankreich und
großbritannien jahrzehnte lang mit
territorialer kontrolle und
militärischen einfluss beschäftigt waren
konzentrierte china alle seine
bemühungen darauf seine beiden großen
wettbewerbsvorteile voll auszunutzen
seine position als fabrik der welt und
seine enorme bevölkerungszahl das ziel
die kings machtausübung durch politische
und wirtschaftliche stadt territorialer
kontrolle um herauszufinden wie die
asiatische gerichte das konkret umsetzt
müssen wir uns nur die fälle von
südkorea australien und litauen ansehen
wie korea australien und litauen fragen
sich jetzt sicher manche von euch was
haben denn die mit china zu tun nun ja
damit war chinas außenpolitik wirklich
verstehen können müssen wir uns an ihrer
tatorte begeben also packt eure lupen
und trenchcoats ein und begleitet mich
auf unserer kleinen weltreise im dienste
der geopolitischen detektivarbeit
obwohl südkorea australien und litauer
und allesamt völlig unterschiedliche
geografische sehr weit voneinander
entfernt sind haben sie dennoch eines
gemeinsam sie haben am eigenen leib
erfahren was es heißt sich mit china
anzulegen 2017 beschloss die
südkoreanische regierung zum beispiel
die installation des us
raketenabwehrsystems page led auf ihrem
territorium zu genehmigen ein vorhaben
dass china von anfang an strikt ablehnt
kickl meinte dass die leistungsstarken
us radare genutzt werden könnten chinas
militärische bewegungen im eigenen land
zu verfolgen
wir haben darüber schon in einem
früheren video gesprochen dass ich euch
die ema verlinken werde auf jeden fall
war zu jener zeit die stimmung in
südkorea aufgrund der ständigen inter
continental raketentest nordkoreas
äußerst angespannt so dass sowohl
schließlich grünes licht für die
stationäre von page led gab trotz
heftigen widerstandes der chinesen das
ergebnis die chinesische regierung
verhängte schonungslose wirtschaftliche
sanktionen und boykotte gegen
südkoreanische unternehmen
deren erste auswirkungen war ein
heftiger kollaps der zahl chinesischer
touristen welche um 50 prozent einbrach
und südkoreanischen unternehmen verluste
in millionenhöhe beschert dann kam der
direkten boykott von unternehmen das
beste beispiel ist die lotte group
südkoreanische unternehmensgruppe welche
der golfplatz gehört auf dem handy
installiert wurde übrigens kleiner fun
fact am rande falls ihr euch fragt warum
ich lotte einfach wie lotte ausspreche
der name der lotte group ist weder
englisch noch koreanisch dann kommt
tatsächlich aus dem deutschen der
konzerngründer chimki hoch war so
begeistert von johann wolfgang von
goethe und besonders von dessen roman
die leiden des jungen werther das in
anlehnung an der romanfigur der
charlotte kurz lotte seiner firma den
gleichen namen gab nun dieser konzern
hatte in china eine große
supermarktkette unter der marke lotte
den chinesen auf einmal nicht mehr
besuchten sagen wir einfach mal die
chinesische regierung hatte ordentlich
dafür gesorgt dass es schnell 5 watt in
den leben der lotte group einzukaufen
zumindest gab es wohl nicht so viele
social tools von winnie the pooh für
lotte shopper und natürlich wurde auch
jeder lizenz zur eröffnung neuer läden
eine absage erteilt das ergebnis die
lotte group musste schließlich ihren
kompletten rückzug aus china ankündigen
ebenso hörten millionen von chinesen
damit auf was heute von hyundai und kia
handys und geräte von samsung und so
weiter zu kaufen so ging es noch ganze
zwei jahre lang weiter bis peking da
2009/10 endlich entschied das ist von
seinen vergeltungsmaßnahmen jetzt genug
hatte und die angelegenheit zu den akten
legte andere länder hingegen hatten
nicht so viel glück schauen sie uns zum
beispiel den fall australiens an
trotz seiner engen partnerschaft mit den
vereinigten staaten ist australien ein
wichtiger handelspartner für china und
beliefert das reich der mitte mit
rohstoffen die seine industrie dringend
benötigt wie zum beispiel kohle eisen
und erdgas außerdem liefert ist eine
große vielfalt an landwirtschaftlichen
produkten zwischen 2009 und 2010 haben
sich dann australischen exporte nach
china auf über 110 milliarden dollar
verdreifacht
die ganzen probleme bringen im jahr 2020
an als die australische regierung eine
unabhängige internationale untersuchung
über die ursprünge der kogit 19 pandemie
verlangte und diese forderung führte zu
einem gravierenden einschnitt in den
australisch chinesischen beziehungen
kaum war eine woche nach der
australischen anfrage vergangen drohte
der chinesische botschafter in kelbra
mit einem wirtschaftsboykott und dieser
ließ nicht lange auf sich warten peking
die reduzierte zb die einfuhren
australischer kohle schrittweise bis auf
null und führte einen ganzen haufen
zölle auf güter eigentlich china aus
australien bezog darunter gerste fleisch
wein kupfer holz die strafe war
beträchtlich
aber wisst ihr was das ganze ging nach
hinten los für die chinesen kelbra hat
nicht nur nicht nachgegeben sondern auch
seine außenpolitik komplett umgekrempelt
und dieser arrogante versuchte chinesen
down under zu unterwerfen und die
bewundernswerte standhaftigkeit der
australier von der sich so manch
opportunistisches land mal eine
gewaltige scheibe abschneiden könnte
verdient unserer meinung nach sogar so
viel beachtung dass wir in kürze noch
ein eigenes video dazu herausbringen
werden das heißt unserem kanal also noch
nicht abonniert hat dann macht das jetzt
bitte schnell und aktiviere auch das
glöckchen um in zukunft keines unserer
videos mehr zu verpassen ich danke dir
und vielleicht sagt euch auch der name
ob muss oder ob es etwas das neue
militär ist zwischen großbritannien den
usa und australien
natürlich sagt dass euch etwas wir haben
ja erst kürzlich hier auf das wort
politik davon berichtet den link zum
video bekommt ihr natürlich sofort unten
in der beschreibung unia dass es zu
diesen abkommen so schnell kam hatte
auch viel mit pekings aus rom gegen
kempter zu tun auf dem rutschigen
parkett der diplomatie wird nämlich fast
nichts dem zufall überlassen australiens
jahrzehntelanger balanceakt zwischen den
usa und china ist vorbei es hat sich für
washington entschieden
australien erhält das erste atom-u-boot
fünf jahre früher als geplant amerikas
als 90 milliarden dollar projekt
angesichts wachsender spannungen mit
china beschleunigt übrigens hat die wohl
vor ihrer strategie ebenfalls südkorea
auch nicht viel gebracht dass die ezb
wird trotz des boykotts weiter betrieben
und wenn wir ehrlich sind es scheint
nicht gerade so als würde china seine
rolle als enfant terrible gut bekommen
hengst lang durch lebt nämlich gerade
die schlimmste diplomatische phase seit
der jahrtausendwende
aber das ist doch nicht das ende der
fahnenstange das jüngste beispiel für
diese sehr unangenehme wohl borriello
matti findet sich in einem kleinen land
das sogar teil der eu ist in litauen
[Musik]
aus sorge über chinas wachsende
politische einmischung beschloss litauen
aus dem 17 + 1 format auszutreten einer
initiative pekings die alle mittel und
osteuropäischen länder zusammen bringen
wollte um sie zu dicken freunden des
pseudo kommunistischen regimes zu machen
liegt da uns nein wir viel china schon
mal da nicht aber der tropfen der das
fass letztendlich zum überlaufen brachte
war die erlaubnis und vilnius anteil
waren eine auslandsvertretung in der
litauischen hauptstadt offen und das
auch noch unter ihrem tatsächlichen
namen dh als taiwan repräsentativ es
anstelle von taipeh repräsentiert auf es
wie es eigentlich üblich ist um dem
eifersüchtigen peking nicht zu sehr auf
die hühneraugen zu treten tja und in
diesem augenblick begann ist nur so
sanktionen zu hageln
die chinesische regierung hat das kleine
littau und einfach so komplett aus
seinem system gestrichen was bedeutet
dass unternehmen aus der kleinen
baltischen republik ihre produkte nicht
mehr direkt ins reich der mitte
exportieren können doch damit nicht
genug die chinesische regierung sitzt
auch europäische unternehmen die in
china produzieren unter druck damit sie
keine komponenten aus litauen verwenden
das war zum beispiel beim deutschen
automobilzulieferer continental der fall
liegt auf exporte werden wegen des
bahnstreiks fast vollständig vom
chinesischen markt verdrängt chinesische
soldaten geben einen ersten einblick in
das ausmaß der inoffiziellen blockade im
dezember gingen lieferungen aus dem
baltischen staat um 91,4 prozent zurück
doch wie wir bereits in den vorherigen
fällen gesehen haben scheint auch hier
tätigen denkzettel nicht viel gebracht
zu haben
[Musik]
litauen hat nämlich seine beziehungen zu
taiwan nur noch weiter gestärkt und die
srx oder die europäische union
vergeltungsmaßnahmen eu erarbeitet neue
maßnahmen gegen wirtschaftliche nötigung
die europäische kommission will sich
wirtschaftliche erpressung wie die von
china nicht länger gefallen lassen
frankreich verspricht rasches handeln
gegen china und will tauen im
handelskrieg aus der patsche helfen
schließlich der die eu in handelsfragen
immer einen einheitlichen block da und
muss gegenüber außenhandelspartner
geschlossen auftreten jeder erfolgreiche
spaltung versucht der union durch peking
würde den anfang vom ende der eu
darstellen bisher scheint es so dass die
wolfsburger diplomatie nicht viele
erfolge erzielt sie hat in südkorea
nicht funktioniert sie hat in australien
nicht funktioniert und sie funktioniert
auch nicht in litauen selbst in taiwan
zeigte man sich von ihr unbeeindruckt
als china 2016 nach zeit und wenn es
erstmal sie kein boykott gegen den
tourismus und den schüleraustausch
startete eine weitere rohrkrepierer für
peking war der verband
wolle huawei
[Musik]
kanadische behörde steckten sie aufgrund
eines auslieferungsersuchens der usa
wegen sanktions verletzungen gegen den
iran in hausarrest und hielten sie dort
fast drei jahre lang fest es war jedoch
nicht der massive druck der chinesischen
wolfs kriege oder die kanadier zur
freilassung der huawei managerin bewegte
sondern einfach weil das us
justizministerium seien verfahren gegen
mengen nach einem deal mit rwe
einstellte und all diese fälle zeigen
chinas diplomatische position scheint
heute ist dünner und exponierte zu sein
als noch vor ein paar jahren in peking
scheinen manche nicht zu verstehen dass
dialog ruhige verhandlungen und gesten
des guten willens man kann also besseren
ergebnissen führen als abschreckung
erpressung und zwar aber es sieht ganz
danach aus als würde jeder schlag von
politiker die sich narzisstisch
nationalistisch als action helden als
krieger sehen dass so einige zeit die
oberhand in der sogenannten
kommunistische partei chinas zu behalten
und damit auch in der weltpolitik den
ton anzugeben da wir diese entwicklung
für unser aller zukunft als überaus
wichtig erachten sie jedoch in den
meisten medien nur unterrepräsentiert
behandelt wird werden wir in nächster
zeit über die außenbeziehungen chinas zu
anderen ländern und die damit
verbundenen perspektiven für die ganze
welt eine ganze serie von videos
herausbringen als erste länder werden
wir schon bald drei schlüssel länder in
der region australien südkorea und
vietnam und deren verhältnis zum roten
riesen unter die lupe nehmen vergesst
also bitte nicht visual politik zu
abonnieren um das glöckchen zu
aktivieren falls ihr dieses thema auch
so interessant findet die wir aber jetzt
seid ihr erstmal mit eurer eigenen
meinung an was haltet ihr von china ist
wohl vor allem aktiv wie sollten die
betroffenen ländern damit umgehen und
was sollten die internationalen
großmächte tun und was haltet ihr von
der diplomatischen linie eures landes
gegenüber peking wie immer sind wir auf
eure kommentare schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat was ja gibt uns geht ein leichtes
und freunde und vergesst nicht ist aber
mit blog heißt unsere videos müssen
verpassten natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
der er uns hilft dieses projekt
weiterzuführen den paypal link dazu
findet ihr beschreibung unter dem video
machs gut und ist bald
[Musik]